we have another spectacular show of guts
glory and gore for you today
[Music]
is
[Music]
is
[Music]
your face on tv
[Music]
go
hunting time
oh
[Music]
[Music]
got it senpai
excellent
[Applause]
that was your first look at death verse
let it die coming to ps4 and ps5 next
year
now let's listen in on a recording
session with we are ofk
[Music]
war
war sucks
in a world full of war where war is um
just doesn't have anything to do with
politics or race or
imperialism out there we look to each
other and to our
thick arms
you done and you're like how did they
get them that thick is this like an
alternate reality where
arms are just that thick or are they
robot arms
our last hope
is arms
luca focus okay okay sorry for real
playstation promo time yeah i'm just
supposed to introduce our band and the
game about our band right oh can we do
something fun with it like can we be
like why is it called state of play what
are we the president
the what are we the we've talked about
these jokes
hey you hi
we're still driving jay i heard back
from the mix engineer and she's cool
with getting song stems on sunday itsu
how's the playstation blog post going
our hashtags too much
i want to reach more people but i don't
think i trust people who use hashtags uh
you two you're the best at this i'm
proud of you
i just do things
carter what you working on
just a little audio filter i cooked up
for debug here can diva make me sound
like a demon
okay
uh give me one more run through and
we'll take a proper break yeah okay hi
we are ofk is a new music biopic game
about us the indie pop group ofk
it's a five episode series about how we
started the band here in los angeles
and how so far we have not screwed it up
you get dialogue choices and texting and
flirting and each episode lets you play
an interactive music video of a new song
from our debut ep that's five episodes
five songs
and if you join our mailing list today
you get a life-size cutout of our whole
band wearing nothing but playstation 5
dual sense controllers oh god no
nope okay the cutout is still tbd but we
are ofk is coming to playstation 5 and
playstation 4 in 2022 the future the
future thick arms we are
ofk okay bye we love you
up next the team at young horses shares
a big update coming to bug snacks
[Music]
oh
you all see that
giant bug snacks
gosh we might be witnessing a
prehistoric species somehow preserved at
the bottom of the ocean
we need to form an expedition
[Music]
uh bro
has anybody seen my hat
snacks with hats that's adorable
and that's not all buddy tada
we finally finished your hot so keep
checking your mail do some redecorating
and before you know it this'll feel like
home
[Music]
can we stop wasting time and get on with
this expedition before i'm as old as
shelder
ready yourself
a brave dangerous
[Music]
hey five nights at freddy's fans we've
got a security breach
ladies and gentlemen thank you for
visiting and we hope you enjoyed the
show freddy and the gang are pretty
tired but they'll be back again next
week after a few days of scheduled
maintenance
freddy fazbear's mega pizza plex is now
closed initiating nighttime protocols no
no wait i'm still
i'm gonna here you i like you
[Music]
[Music]
you should be able to escape with the
security doors reopen at 6am
until then keep moving and try not to
draw attention to yourself if there is
another way out i will help you find it
i promise
[Music]
[Music]
please make your way to the front of the
building where you will be given novelty
glasses a voucher for one free soda
refill and where you will sign a legal
disclaimer releasing us of all liability
for anything that might have happened
during your visit
have an awesome night and we'll see you
again soon
[Music]
would you like to take a short survey
about your experience
battle beasts and demigods in a
challenging action rpg coming soon to
playstation let's take a look
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
online opponents await in these
multiplayer games coming to ps4 and ps5
[Music]
one way
[Music]
[Music]
i'll get you
[Music]
i'll trick ya
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
shatter all expectations
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
once
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
um
15.
[Music]
escape is futile
looks like you're in need of your
medicine
hi everyone i'm niels also known as
vaderberg hi everyone i'm emily also
known as norsteph
today we're excited to share first class
trouble with you first class trouble is
an online social deduction game
featuring a dangerous cocktail of
difficult decisions and wacky
possibilities
before you hop into a match check out
the range of customization options
available to you as you play you'll
unlock even more so don't forget to come
back to your wardrobe from time to time
let's check out that recent match we
played that was a good one
when the round begins you'll be assigned
a secret role of either a resident or a
personnoid
so this is me i played as a resident in
this game and my goal was to reach kane
at the heart of the iss alicia and i got
to play as a personnoid so my game was
all about deception and traps stopping
the residents at all costs great outfit
that you have on there thank you the
most important question is
who can you trust yeah exactly and i
thought you and i were working together
i know right
sometimes going with your gut doesn't
work out
sorry dave i don't have that problem you
sabotage the oxygen well done
when a system is sabotaged or a trap is
sprung this is a good time to start
casting doubt on the loyalty of the
other residents yeah you had me so
convinced you did such a great job i
even helped you take him out you really
got me on this game i never suspected
you at any point sorry not sorry yeah
here it is gotcha i realized too late
whether you're a personnoid or resident
your social deduction skills and
strategy are the key to survival good
luck everyone and remember be careful
who you trust because in first class
trouble cocktails last longer than
friendships
work together to avoid disaster when
first class trouble arrives to ps4 and
ps5 next month playstation plus members
will be able to download the ps4 and ps5
versions at no extra cost starting
november 2nd
scanning craft pan galactic federation
battleship the astoria weapons activity
detected ready
thrusters to full power there's no time
no way
abandoned ship all crew members get to
an escape
[Music]
my
[Music]
are you quite all right
let's help your offering then it's help
i'm taking
[Music]
damn near the full federation fleet's
moving in on us
i am certain your journey into the stars
above
will bring hope to the future of this
world
spare yourself righteousness i shall be
saved by my own hands
if humanity should persist as it has
never will it find total freedom from
sorrow what hope do we hold should they
descend upon us now
if you dare turn your back to this i
swear i'll destroy the federation shift
by ship until there's not a damn thing
left
before we wrap up let's get an update on
the eagerly awaited little devil inside
[Music]
many
[Music]
like any other day
billy sets out on another job
looks like he's reading the letter he
received
the job seems simple enough
billy arrives at cornfield station
he needs to meet professor vincent who
should be nearby
oh
there's an old lady up ahead
during travel you can engage with
various people
sometimes to buy goods or simply ask for
directions
[Music]
on certain occasions the crew is
available to travel together
during world map travel you can
encounter various events
some bigger than others
in this case a flock of sheep blocking
the road
[Music]
looks like they have arrived near their
destination
billy heads towards an eerie looking
mansion to fulfill his
simple task of course
he's greeted by who seems like the owner
the job is to pick up a mysterious
artifact and deliver it to professor
vincent
looks like it's kept in the mansion's
basement
leaving behind the unsettling signs on
the wall
billy enters the basement chamber
well
it turns out that the job is not going
to be so simple after all
ever since leaving the mansion
strange looking creatures constantly
appeared
here he is surrounded by a mob
striking and sticking the blade into
enemies to pull and throw them around
during his travels billy needs to resort
to his survival instincts and make use
of whatever he has to survive
often being exposed to the harsh side of
mother nature
a desert environment is one such place
finding safe places to camp and cooking
up food is all part of the journey
this time a sub-zero climate and worse
caught in a snow blizzard
struggling to pull his companion out of
the snow
what will be their fate
lead billy throughout his journey
and imagine what he has to face
some expected
more often not
[Music]
oh my
welcome to the world of little devil
inside
[Music]
that's our show we hope you enjoyed this
peek into what's to come on playstation
see you next time
[Music]
you